a gossip economy oh yeah I feel like
we're all doing versions of the view so
true like yeah lizzo and Jonah Hill and
we do we love it and we act like oh I'm
above all this but we're in on it your
thought leaders now are like college
dropouts with podcasts and content pages
and they're doing it I am doing this for
you I care about the issue but really
it's like they refresh and go how many
likes how many clicks well I think uh
you got to keep upping it you got to
keep upping the drama because like we
have aliens here and no one gives a
because we're like what aliens we're on
this true crime right now this is
way more fun and you're like but there's
a martian in Phoenix and they're like ah
this lady killed her husband and her dog
and all that you're like that's way more
salacious you're like but this is a
martian from another land and they're
like ah when the Martian says something
racist call me that's why martians are
boring they're boring they're murdering
any women yes that would put them on the
map misgender someone you
Martian and now you'll get the news
you're not in the cultural Zeitgeist
exactly